If you take a peek at a list of pilots who
were considered flying aces during WW2, you’ll
notice that the top of the list is dominated
by Luftwaffe pilots, some of whom scored hundreds
of aerial victories during the war.
While their skill and prowess in the air is
undeniable, it’s arguable that the finest
display in aerial combat during WW2 was achieved,
mostly by luck, by an American B-24 co-pilot
when he scored a single enemy kill with nothing
but a handgun, at about 4,000-5,000 feet (about
1.3 km) in altitude, and without a plane.
This is the story of Owen Baggett.
Born in 1920 in Texas, after finishing high
school, Baggett moved to the city of Abilene
to enroll in Hardin–Simmons University.
While we were unable to discern what Baggett
studied from the sparse amount of information
available about his early life, the fact that
he went to work at Johnson and Company Investment
Securities in New York after graduating suggests
he studied finance, business, or another similar
subject.
Whatever the case, while still working at
the investment firm in New York in December
of 1941, Baggett volunteered for the Army
Air Corps and reported for basic pilot training
at the New Columbus Army Flying School.
After graduating from basic training, Baggett
reported for duty in India, just a stone’s
throw away from Japanese occupied Burma with
the Tenth Air Force.
Baggett eventually became a co-pilot for a
B-24 bomber in the 7th Bomb Group based in
Pandaveswar and reached the rank of 2nd Lieutenant.
During his time with the 7th Bomb Group, Baggett’s
duties mainly consisted of flying bombing
runs into Burma and helping defend allied
supply routes between India and China.
Baggett’s career was mostly uneventful,
or at least as uneventful as it could be given
the circumstances, for around a year until
he was called upon to take part in a bombing
run on March 31, 1943.
The mission itself was fairly simple- Baggett
and the rest of the 7th Bomb Group were to
fly into Burma and destroy a small, but vital
railroad bridge near the logging town of Pyinmana.
However, shortly after taking off, the (unescorted)
bombers of the 7th Bomb Group were attacked
by a few dozen Japanese Zero fighters.
During the ensuing dogfight, the plane’s
emergency oxygen tanks were hit, severely
damaging the craft.
Ultimately, 1st Lt. Lloyd Jensen gave the
order for the crew to bailout.
Baggett relayed the order to the crew using
hand signals (since their intercom had also
been destroyed) and leapt from the aircraft
with the rest of the surviving crew.
Not long after the crew bailed out, the attacking
Japanese Zeros began training their guns on
the now-defenceless crewman lazily floating
towards the ground.
Baggett would later recall seeing some of
his crewmates being torn to pieces by gunfire
(in total 5 of the 9 aboard the downed bomber
were killed).
As for himself, a bullet grazed his arm, but
he was otherwise fine.
In a desperate bid to stay that way, after
being shot in the arm, Baggett played possum,
hanging limp in his parachute’s harness.
According to a 1996 article published in Air
Force Magazine, this is when Baggett spotted
an enemy pilot lazily flying along almost
vertically in mid-air to come check out whether
Baggett was dead or not, including having
his canopy open to get a better look at Baggett.
When the near-stalling plane came within range,
Baggett ceased to play dead and pulled out
his M1911 from its holster, aimed it at the
pilot, and squeezed the trigger four times.
The plane soon stalled out and Baggett didn’t
notice what happened after, thinking little
of the incident, being more concerned with
the other fighters taking pot shots at he
and his crew.
After safely reaching the ground, Baggett
regrouped with Lt Jensen and one of the bomber’s
surviving gunners.
Shortly thereafter, all three were captured,
at which point Baggett soon found himself
being interrogated.
After telling the events leading up to his
capture to Major General Arimura, commander
of the Southeast Asia POW camps, very oddly
(as no one else in his little group was given
the opportunity), Baggett was given the chance
to die with honour by committing harakiri
(an offer he refused).
Later, while still a POW, Baggett had a chance
encounter with one Col. Harry Melton.
Melton informed him that the plane that Baggett
had shot at had crashed directly after stalling
out near him and (supposedly) the pilot’s
body had been thrown from the wreckage.
When it was recovered, he appeared to have
been killed, or at least seriously injured,
via having been shot, at least according to
Colonel Melton.
Despite the fact that the plane had crashed
after his encounter with it, Baggett was still
skeptical that one (or more) of his shots
actually landed and figured something else
must have happened to cause the crash.
Nevertheless, it was speculated by his compatriots
that this must have been the reason Baggett
alone had been given the chance to die with
honour by committing harakiri after being
interrogated.
Baggett never really talked about his impressive
feat after the fact, remaining skeptical that
he’d scored such a lucky shot.
He uneventfully served the rest of his time
in the war as a POW, dropping from a hearty
180 pounds and change to just over 90 during
the near two years he was kept prisoner.
The camp he was in was finally liberated on
September 7, 1945 by the OSS and he continued
to serve in the military for several years
after WW2, reaching the rank of colonel.
The full details of his lucky shot were only
dug up in 1996 by John L Frisbee of Air Force
Magazine.
After combing the records looking to verify
or disprove the tale, it turned out that while
Col. Harry Melton’s assertion that the pilot
in question had been found with a .45 caliber
bullet wound could not be verified by any
documented evidence, it was ultimately determined
that Baggett must have managed to hit the
pilot.
You see, the plane in question appears to
have stalled at approximately 4,000 to 5,000
feet (so an amazing amount of time for the
pilot to have recovered from the stall had
he been physically able) and, based on official
mission reports by survivors, there were no
Allied fighters in the vicinity to have downed
the fighter and no references of anyone seeing
any friendly fire at the slow moving plane
before its ultimately demise.
Further, even with some sort of random engine
failure, the pilot should have still had some
control of the plane, instead of reportedly
more or less heading straight down and crashing
after
the stall.